joining us now house minority web steve
scalise and florida congressman
michael waltz okay uh mr scalise let's
start with you
first off this is about the senate
debate from what you've seen
from the plan the bipartisan plan do you
think it's going to sail through the
house
well brian i think there's serious
problems with it and look let's keep in
mind
speaker pelosi has made it crystal clear
that the infrastructure bill
is not only the gateway drug but it's
directly linked to
the reconciliation bill which is their
ability to go raise taxes
so it's not only three and a half four
and a half trillion dollars you can't
even
track how many trillions because they
don't want to show you the text as you
just mentioned
but the other part of that is the
reconciliation bill to raise
taxes and kill jobs in america run jobs
to foreign countries
that's what they really want to do and
speaker pelosi's she's not hiding it she
actually said
she's not bringing up one without the
other so they're directly linked
together
it's not about infrastructure it's about
all of those other things the green new
deal
all the far left policy and tax
increases that will kill american jobs
and raise
costs that are already going through the
roof with inflation
you know this is what uh also
republicans point to that they got they
got rid of 40 billion dollars for the
irs to go investigate everybody
and they also are handing over a
bipartisan plan that doesn't increase
taxes
congressman waltz would with the
majority whip his minority whip is
talking about
is elian omar and the rest of the squad
and others say we will not sign off on
this bipartisan bill
unless we have the other one also in
front of us at the same time
this could be a 10 car pileup
yeah brian i mean whip scalise is
absolutely right in that this
is hostage legislating on the part of
speaker pelosi
uh and she is beholden to her left she's
scared of the left
uh and uh you know they're demanding uh
free across the board
plus a green new deal the sad thing is
that we actually do as a country
badly need hard infrastructure roads
ports
bridges you know brian the chinese are
about to build their thousandth
shipyard you know how many we have 24.
uh him we're a maritime nation right
they've built
18 000 miles of high voltage
power lines over the last few years
we've built
zero they've got 5g connecting smart
cities
we still have dial up in our rural areas
we badly need this i think a lot of
republicans very much want to support it
because it's the right thing to do for
our country
it's the connective tissue for our
economy but this hostage legislating
that uh pelosi's doing
you know is the same old same old from
her and this is why we've got to send
her back to california and fire and get
her into retirement in 15 months
so real quick if they hand you that
bipartisan bill as you understand it you
would you sign off on that
uh we would negotiate it down i think
we'll negotiate it down in the house
and then it'll go to some type of
conference with the senate but
look the other thing brian real quick i
don't think they fully have the votes
for that three and a half trillion that
puts a lot of their moderates
in a bad place people are scared of
inflation
uh and they're making the tie a majority
americans are making the tie from those
higher prices
to the out of control spending that's
going on in washington dc
i don't think she has the votes for the
three and a half trillion we're gonna
put her in a box
i find it totally offensive and i want
you guys to hear this the audio is not
great but it's important
reconciliation should be about the
budget and it should be it's a special
thing to allow you to do a simple
majority vote
but guess what joe biden is basically
admitting he's going to try to put into
it
listen to what he said yesterday
it went very well what i think we i
think we should include in the
reconciliation though the immigration
approach
is like that's putting out a message
right now
do a congressman scalise he's saying i'm
going to put
infrastructure immigration
infrastructure in this reconciliation
bill
and they're talking about legalizing 8
million do you know what the border's
going to be like if he's going to
legalize
illegals just slip shot 8 million
right brian and look we've already got a
border crisis because of joe biden's
just crazy policies where now they've
not only got a border crisis
it's a super spreader crisis we see the
delta variant coming in widely and now
the lambda variant
coming in through the southern border
because they're admitting they're
coveted positive
you can't fly back from america as an
american citizen for from mexico
uh without proving your covert negative
but if you come here
as an illegal saying you're covet
positive they let you into the
inner cities of america and so what
you're seeing they want to do the whole
liberal wish list
in the reconciliation bill so it's tax
increases it's the green new deal
and now as president biden's finally
tipping his hat it's about amnesty too
uh they've got an endless wish list of
radical ideas
that they can't get in any other way
except to reconciliation but the only
way they get it
is tying it to that infrastructure bill
we've got to break the two apart
all right it's up to you guys uh you
looked at his leadership uh in the house
even though you're in the minority for
now
only a handful of seats from the
majority uh michael waltz steve scalise
thanks so much guys
thanks brian thanks brian hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else